ich denke ich wäre es mal ein bisschen
in mitte gehen weil ich bin schon sehr
lange am leben und ich finde es einmal
langweilig ihr kennt so viele sachen
form ich bin endlich das komplette
gegenteil von allen anderen youtube ich
find's cool wenn leute erster schreiben
weil die sonne also eine art ziele für
sich erreicht haben
hallo ihr lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen endlich mal wieder zu einer
neuen runde hunger games der typ der
links neben wir jetzt auf dem baum
gespannt
ziemlich heftigen vorteil dadurch jetzt
wir spielen die ganz normale hunger
games map die allererste die
rausgekommen ist der dom hatte ich einen
vorteil er kann er da hinten ist es eher
auf mich kennen hier einige leute weil
das der hdpk server ist
ich habe versucht weiter aufzunehmen das
ist ein spielprinzip von willy brandt
und beide games zusammengefasst auf
einem server ist da kam mir schon einige
youtube-videos veranstaltet
beziehungsweise gedreht nachteil war nur
das nein ich mache kein team mit dem was
macht dieses nachteil war allerdings
dass ich da in wien nicht premium
benziner ich bin da wie youtube oder so
obwohl ich da drauf und er meinte ich
kann auch auf seine volle serverräumen
tja denkste war nicht der fall
wow er kratzt viele sachen ja büro so
war da werde ich nicht mal ganz schnell
mit einer völlig anderen kisten zu
finden also ich werde in nächster zeit
wahrscheinlich mehr pvp sachen
veranstalten am ort reviews natürlich
sehr sehr aufwändig sind und ich davon
jetzt letzter zeit erstmal 45 wieder
gemacht habe dass wir wieder und lieber
zu gucken und pvp sachen finde ich in
letzter zeit guck ich mir selber am
meisten mittlerweile auf youtube an von
anderen deutschen youtube an wie zum
beispiel ungespielt etc die da selber
pvp videos machen natürlich sehr cool
ich mache mir ganz kurz mal eine
geräusche runter ich weiß jetzt nicht
wie lange ich noch eine grace periode
habe periode gewährte
ich brauche kisten ich brauche ich mir
schwer denn ihr seid nun verwundbar ja
okay dann ist die perioden vorbei damit
hält sich das geklärt ich brauche
allerdings wirklich meine kiste damit
ich hier überhaupt irgendwie mit
streiten kann also bei den anderen im
zimmer so wieder kisten und hier sind
echt hier ist echt total wenig hallo
kassenhäuschen da könnte bestimmt was
sagen da könnten ein okay hier ist
bestimmt was drin oder oder oder oder
oder oder ist was dran
geht es nach unten das auch schon mal
gut
ich will nicht rein ich will ja nicht es
ist eine falle ist ob das eine falle
jedoch nicht aber ich kam nicht mehr
raus komme ich heraus was ich glaube das
ist halt es war knapp
ich muss jetzt irgendwie raus kommen ich
glaube ich kommt an tochter sony an
ich habe mir jeden fall zugesagt so als
ich hier so saß so herr luca luka hab
ich mir gesagt habe ich mir gesagt pokal
noch mal wieder eine runde hunger games
auf weil die leute das natürlich auch
mal sehen wollen und nicht nur treu
bleiben will und der mine war und crysis
3 ist jetzt auch angefangen in minecraft
sondern eventuell ein paar andere sachen
und geht ja hier aufgabe hdpk sehr gut
hier oben müsste ich mal wieder
reinarbeiten und trockenem einfach nur
die sache man wird so oft ran abgekühlt
und da hab ich einfach in die keinen
bock drauf und deswegen muss ich schauen
wie ich dass der ganze regeln wer die
übrigen hab ich auch die kompletten
server da et cetera teilen nicht mehr
das heißt ich möchte die ganze server
mal selber eingeben und so darauf habe
ich auch nicht so wirklich bock drauf
naja muss ich schauen ja muss ich schaue
mich das ganze veranstalten werde ich
jetzt erstmal jetzt ein bisschen rum
schwimmen
da ist nix und ich muss irgendwie da
hinten ist ein typ
heuer der gegner sachen internet aber
wisst ihr was ist immer doof wenn man
sachen gibt weil ich will nicht team
machen ich finde allerdings ist
überlebens sache da will ich keine teams
ist zwar nett gemeint aber ich denke ihr
versteht was ich meine
die ganzen sachen sehen aus wie er in
sachen naja ich lasse ihn zweimal
alleine hoffe mal kocht er hat sich
bestimmt alle dauert es noch der kiste
aber die hatte sich bestimmt schon
gegönnt doch vorbei gesprungen
verdi hatte sich schon gewöhnt ja gut
noch 13 spieler sind übrig ich wollte
dieses ganze hier jetzt mal übrigens
nutzen nach vier minuten komme ich jetzt
dass du das thema anzusprechen warum ich
das ja gerade aufnehmen und zwar kennt
doch so mit sicherheit die kommentare
ich bin erst da wo kennt er ist unter
jedem video so wenn man ein bisschen
bekannter ist auf youtube ich möchte ich
gar nicht als bekannt ansehen sondern
einfach nur dass ein paar leute mich
abonniert haben ja es gibt dann die
leute die einfach unter die video
schreiben hey ich bin erst dann alle
regen sich darüber auf
und so aber was ich finde das gar nicht
schlimm ich wollte einfach mal die leute
verteidigen die da erster schreibe ich
meine ich war letztes erster bei einem
video von mädchen immer bei seiner
minecraft animation ist mittlerweile
durch drei millionen aufrufe oder so da
war ich der erste die addiert irgendwie
für kommentare hat die 7000 oder sohn
von 7000 leuten oder von den drei
millionen bin ich ja erst lässt sich
angeguckt haben wir erste der kommentar
geschrieben hat ich hab dann so etwas
geschrieben wie hey cool mal wieder
minecraft animation oder so haben auch
einige dann gesehen hiergegen diesem
tollen youtube ja komm ich wegen diesem
tollen youtube blog teil dingsbums
sache war dann allerdings dass ich da
komme hierhin sache war dann allerdings
das also was ich eigentlich sagen ich
bin halt diese fokussiert auf diesen
typen weil ich nicht weiß ob das hier
hin will oder weg will ich finde es
einfach mal dahin sache ist allerdings
dass halt viele ich bin erst darunter
schreiben verstehen was daran so schlimm
ist weil ich meine die sagen ich bin
erst da und gut also diesen erste oder
freuen sie sich dass doch klar man freut
sich über solche auf soll aber auch über
solche kleinen dinge im leben sollte man
sich ruhig freuen
und was ich eigentlich das einzig
schlimme daran ist finde ich wenn ein
leute ankommen diese person beleidigen
und zwar so etwas schreiben wie e dur
sohn und so was alles ich finde sowas
hat eigentlich nichts auf youtube zu
suchen weil wir eine community sind wir
sollten zusammenhalt und wenn dann
einmal erster ist dann kennt man ihnen
das und ich denke wenn ihr selber erster
sein würde dann würdet ihr auch erster
schreiben auch das allerbeste war so ein
typ schreibt beleidigt eine person mit
so hey du willst aber muscle cars und
einen tag später war er zufälligerweise
wirklich erster ich wünschte ich hätte
ein spleen shop gemacht allerdings hat
er den kommentar diese beleidigung dann
gelöscht nachdem ich darauf eingegangen
bin war er dann selber erster bei mir
und hat dann selber erst darunter
geschrieben also da sieht man das
wirklich das hauptsache andere
beleidigen und dann selber nicht besser
machen
da ist er lumpen so ich geh jetzt auf
den turm dahinten das wollte ich mal
eben sagen dass ich das eigentlich gar
nicht schlimm finde und ihr dürft unter
meine videos ruhig erst darunter
schreiben ich wollte doch eigentlich mal
so eine aktion machen das immer der typ
der erste darunter schreibt er wird im
nächsten video dann erwägen beziehung
als einer von den ersten hundert
kommentare irgendwie sowas oder der halt
erst hat unterschreibt wir dann erwähnt
einfach nur damit
da sind damit ich so eine gegenbewegung
starte damit man sich freut erster zu
sein wir noch schnell kommentar schreibt
weil das es doch einfach so eine sache
dass man sich dann freut
also ich würde mich auf jeden fall
freuen wenn ich der erste bin denkt und
videos schaut von einer person die ich
mag
also ich finde das cool diese sind da
setzlinge drin mich verarschen
ja also das ist meine meinung zu der
ganzen debatte ihr könnt mir einfach
eure meinung in die kommentare schreiben
ich hab gedacht ich mach ersten kontakt
darüber habe ich dann allerdings doch
sein lassen weil ich will das ganze
jetzt nicht kontinent weil ich das ja
nicht im nachhinein aufnehmen sondern
nebenbei einfach so mal live eine runde
halbe games ich bin erst da so denke ich
fit zu sein oder als universitätslehrer
ich denke ich werde es mir ein bisschen
in mitte gehen weil ich bin schon sehr
lange am leben und ich finde es ja mal
langweilig die kennt so viele sache für
mich bedenklich das komplette gegenteil
von allen anderen youtube an
ich find's cool wenn leute erster
schreiben weil die sonne als eine art
ziele für sich erreicht haben und wir
haben das auch letztens werten dass sich
in pädagogik ich habe keinen pädagogik
aber es gibt einen pädagogischen zustand
der nennt sich bobby heißt sehr toll
effekt nein hall effekt war was anderes
paul effekt wenn man mit irgendwas nicht
aufhören kann zum beispiel die ganze
zeit irgendwie toffifee essen obwohl man
weiß dass es schlechte gesundheit ist
hat man trotzdem alter sogar zwei mal
schauen ob man damit trotzdem nicht auf
weil ihr lernt bei mir nicht so viel
weil kein halt spaß macht erzählt lecker
schmeckt obwohl man natürlich das risiko
weise zwar davon vechte zuckerschock
oder diabetes oder irgendwie sowas
kriegen kann ja hier auch eine chance
gesetzlich damit soll
na gut mathematisch karriere ist kurz 43
okay das ist doch besser
ja also ich find's cool wenn man erst
darunter schreibt ich fasse es lange zu
überleben bei den hunger games aber nur
total langweilig dann ist das heißt ich
suche eigentlich immer relativ schnell
das abenteuer zu entscheiden haye will
ich jetzt gut oder hey vielleicht doch
nicht so blöd dass ich beide gegessen
habe weil das eine hätte mir das leben
schon auf gefüllte schweine
ich lege irgendwie ein bisschen naja
passiert da schauen einfach mit wie
viele leute leben eigentlich noch ich
weiß es geht gar nicht
18 gut habe ich dahin gesehen gegen den
ob ich auf jeden fall eine chance hat er
keine items hat aber hier sind noch ein
paar andere leute irgendwo auf der welt
verteilt ich kann aber einfach aus spaß
100 angreifen nämlich auch ein bisschen
was zu tun
ich schaue erst mal ganz kurz wurde die
wette war ich doch die diva die geschehe
ich meine die bitte war hier übrigens
hat man wahrscheinlich dass ich immer
noch ein bisschen erkältet bin ich bin
bei mir ist das so ich bin erkältet dann
bin ich ja nicht erkältet erkältet dass
keine kiste also bei mir ist das dann so
ein kommen und gehen
so wie in einer einkaufsmeile höhe so
dass ein schaf das durch die mittel oder
oder oder
aber da sind große bäume und großen
bäumen
doch jetzt die mitte in großen bäumen
oft irgendwelche kiste oder das spiel
verlassen
dabei ist es sind neun spieler noch
vielleicht hat irgendjemand was das
weitergeben was hier dienen lassen
das sind mit schwert mehr als nötig
rausbekommen der opfer ich weiß es weil
es ein bisschen asozial aber ich finde
es in hunger games man da muss man sich
verarscht das genauso wie bei triplemind
will und werde nicht weiß was das jetzt
also selber lesen keine ahnung so
goldschmidt ist deshalb sind eisen
schwert ich weise nicht jetzt erst mal
höre er von der bürger drauf familiären
oder so noch münchen ich nehme jetzt mal
das holzschwert für die münchen
übrigens ist mir aufgefallen dass ich
immer besser ein pvp werde ich meine ich
habe es drei miteinander hunger games
gespielt und das halt aufzunehmen aber
ich würde alle drei mal erster ich weiß
ich bin kräftiger befürworter der these
dass meine minecraft kein pro pvp typ
sein kann weil es geht einfach nicht
wieso schmeiße alle das verlinken oder
so der schmeißen wir gerade hören zu
auch sehr cool finde ich zwar scheiße
aber sollen wir machen
denn ist wieder unser kollege von vorhin
der jetzt auch ein anderer glaubt nicht
dass ich das schaffe bleibt doch stehen
mensch
wieso läuft einen weg der der hat
bessere sachen als ich mein kind nicht
locker und panschens lag der jonas
rummel den glaubst wohl nicht oder wenn
ich das delikt der legt wenn er so rockt
das heißt ich muss warten oder das ist
einfach der server weil das war bei
gomez schon öfters schon mal gesagt dass
die server von ihm einfach der buggy
läuft alles legt ich hoffe das lag mit
zu sehr zum leid fand schon die beiden
da hinten sich denn jetzt oder wie läuft
das ärgert mich zu sehr
da komme ich gar nicht mit klar das sind
einfach die server sind total im arsch
gerade ich denke es ist wird mich nicht
wundern wenn ich jeden moment aus dem
spiel geklickt werden würde bzw
der komplette server abstürzt jetzt bin
ich wieder hier noch so ach so läuft das
also mein schwert ist auf einmal kaputt
auch so ich bin im moment ja ich bin tot
ich habe keinen plan warum ich fand ich
mal richtig schlagen keller server hier
läuft wieder alles flüssig der prinz
dieser typ gute freunde das wasser mit
einer runden hunger games ist gefallen
könnte einfach eine positive bewertung
abgeben bzw
daumen hoch bzw leiten das zeigt mir ob
es euch gefallen hat oder nicht ob ich
mehr machen soll oder nicht
und einfach ob euch das allgemeinen
gefällt und ihr mehrere videos davon
haben soll dazu ist die like funktion
dar
oder wirklich sagen wir lieben freundin
sehen wir uns in der nächsten folge
games endet noch eine haben wollt könnt
ihr einfach in die kommentare schreiben
besitzt beim nächsten mal